ليله سابدا من اخر خبر ذكرتيه هو موضوع
محور فيلادلفيا والتوغل في هذه المنطقه
الجنوبيه لقطاع غزه عندما نتحدث عن هذه
المنطقه فنحن نتحدث عن الشريط الذي يمتد
لحوالي 14 كيل مترا الشريط الحدودي بين
قطاع غزه واسرائيل من البحر من شارع
الرشيد وصولا الى نقطه معبر كرم ابو سالم
ونقطه كيرم شالوم هذا المعبر معبر كرم ابو
سالم هو المعبر الذي يربط ثلاثه نقاط في
نفس الوقت هو يدخل الى قطاع غزه والى
اسرائيل والى مصر ومنه تدخل بعض الحمولات
والمساعدات التي تدخل الى قطاع غزه وهو
كان معبرا تجاريا ا تدخل منه البضائع من
مصر الى قطاع غزه ومن اسرائيل الى قطاع
غزه اذا هو نقطه التقاء على ثلاثه حدود
يبدو الامر حتى هذه اللحظه لا توجد كثير
من التفاصيل ولكن يبدو ان هناك محاوله
للتوغل من هذه الجهه من الجهه من الجهه
الاراضي الاسرائيليه و داخل الخط الاخضر
باتجاه منطقه رفح وهذا هو معبر رفح بطبيعه
الحال المغلق حاليا والذي يمتد من شارع
صلاح الدين الى هذه النقطه ويدخل الى
الاراضي المصريه الذي حصل اليوم ان قوه
اسرائيليه يبدو انها حاولت التوغل في هذه
المنطقه وانه تم التصدي لها وفق ما اعلن
الجيش الاسرائيلي انه تم قتل مسلحين تصدي
للقوه الاسرائيليه المتوغلة
حاله الفراغ في هذه المناطق وبالتالي
التوغل في هذه المنطقه سيكون سهلا بالنسبه
لقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اذا ما ارادت
الهجوم على مدينه رفح في هذه النقطه ولكن
الذي يحدث الان او الذي يشاع الان من
اخبار ان اسرائيل تسعى للضغط على كل
الحدود التي نشاهدها على الشاشه وبالتالي
عزل قطاع غزه عن الاراضي المصريه ولكن هذا
الامر تزامن مع عمليات عسكريه مكثفه
لكتائب القسام في منطقه خان يونس ومنطقه
جحر الديك في المنطقه الوسط والمنطقه
الشماليه اذا ما تحدثنا عن منطقه خانيونس
فنحن نتحدث عن الحدث الابرز في خانيونس
اليوم وهو قتل اربعه من اربعه من جنود
الاحتلال من وحده يا هالوم او الماسا
باللغه العربيه وهذه وحده تابعه لسلاح
الهندسه الاسرائيلي يبدو كما قالت كتاب
القسام بانها استطاعت استدراج هذه الوحده
الى منطقه الشرقيه من مدينه خان يونس وهذه
مدينه خان يونس التي نشاهدها على الشاشه
هذه قلب مدينه خنوس التي يسعى الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بطبيعه الحال الى دخولها والتو
فيها وقد استطاع هو الدخول من هذه المنطقه
من منطقه بن سهيلا ومن منطقه الزن وم
منطقه القراره ومن منطقه مدينه حمد يحاصر
مدينه خانيونس ولكنه لم يدخلها حتى الان
يبدو ان الحدث اليوم حصل في هذه النقطه في
شرق مدينه خانيونس او بين بنس هيلا وخان
يونس وهو استدراج خمسه من قوات وحده يالوم
كما ذكرنا وحده تابعه لسلاح الهندسه تعتبر
وحده نخبوي في سلاح الهندسه تم استدراجهم
الى هذا النفق وبعد دخولهم ال النفق تم
تفجير نفق وقتل خمسه من عناصر هذه الوحده
وكان حدثا بارزا في منطقه خان يونس في
المنطقه الجنوبيه اذا ما انتقلنا الى
المنطقه الشماليه فهناك حدثان رئيسيان
اولا الاحداث التي ت توالت اليوم في منطقه
جحر الديك ولكن قبل ذلك كان هناك احداث
مهمه في منطقه جباليا البلد ومخيم جباليا
الذي لا يزال يشهد قتالا عنيفا بين قوات
الاحتلال هناك جباليا البلد المدينه
القديمه او البلده القديمه في جباليا
وهناك م مخيم جباليا للاجئين الف
فلسطينيين في مخيم الجباليه تقول كتائب
القسام بانها قتلت اربع جنود وضباط
اسرائيليين من المسافه صفر في حي القصاصيب
في مخيمي جباليا اجهزت عليهم ب بشكل كامل
هكذا يب يكون المجموعه الذي قتلتهم قوات
المقاومه الفلسطينيه او كتاب القسام وفق
ما اعلنت الكتائب بشكل واضح اليوم خمسه في
خان يونس واربعه في مخيم جباليا بالاضافه
لاعداد الاستهدافات الاخرى ابرز
الاستهدافات كانت اليوم جحر الديك التي
عادت الى الواجهه من جديد مع الضغط الكبير
الذي شكلته جحر الديك اليوم على قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مع دخول اربع جبات
اسرائيليه الى منطقه جحر الديك في هذه
المنطقه دخلت الجبات الاسرائيليه كما قالت
كتاب القسام الى منطقه جحر الديك في هذه
المنطقه استدرجتها قوات كتائب القسام
وفجرت في كمين محكم كما قالت الكتائب جحر
الديك تعود الى الواجهه من جديد لانها قبل
عده ايام ايضا نفذت كتاب القسام كمينا
مركبا في هذه المنطقه وهذه منطقه بهذا
الشكل تقريبا تتجاوز مساحتها 6ه كيلومترات
مربعه لا تزال المقاومه الفلسطينيه تضرب
فيها وبقوه لانها من اوائل المناطق التي
توغلت فيها اليات قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي هذا